[Música]
cómo
estos calvinistas no han faltado a una
sola misa dominical es desde que
comenzaron las restricciones sanitarias
estamos en el corazón de una región de
los países bajos llamada cinturón de la
biblia porque alberga una comunidad de
protestantes conservadores algunas
mujeres siguen llevando el traje
tradicional frente a la iglesia nuestra
cámara es recibida con una fría
bienvenida pero a linda y su madre
aceptan reunirse con nosotros en su casa
para estas devotas creyentes es
imposible imaginar que no recién juntas
con regularidad incluso en tiempos de
pandemia los domingos en la misa
estamos todos juntos eso es lo mejor de
ir a la iglesia
en la iglesia nos encontramos con dios
por supuesto esto también es posible en
casa pero la iglesia es realmente el
taller de dios
las autoridades neerlandesas recomiendan
que los creyentes se queden en casa pero
según la constitución cada iglesia sigue
siendo libre de decidir el otro problema
es que una pequeña parte de esta
comunidad un 3% de la población se opone
al principio de la vacunación este
hombre quiere testificar con la cara
oculta está rodeado por sus siete hijos
ninguno de los cuales ha recibido una
sola vacuna
no nos vacunaremos contra el coronavirus
y era
porque creemos que el señor decide si
estamos enfermos o sanos
y queremos que siga siendo así creemos
en no enfermar el cuerpo con una droga
que permita evitar que el señor nos
castigue de nuestras posiciones
radicales que estos creyentes justifican
en los textos de la biblia la vacunación
es una forma de prevención de algo peor
pero para conseguir este resultado le
inocula la enfermedad para algunos
creyentes este efecto no es aceptable si
dios quiere enfermarte de enfermar pero
un humano no puede al igual que en su
sermón de la montaña jesús dijo no te
preocupes por el mañana yo cuidaré de ti
para estos cristianos estos textos son
muy importantes para justificar su
postura de que no nos vamos a enfermar
sin embargo la tasa más alta de contagio
en los países bajos también se encontró
en esta región no es una sorpresa para
este médico general que recibe
regularmente a protestantes calvinistas
calcula que el 30 por ciento de sus
pacientes se han visto afectados por el
virus
hubo muchos contagios es un pueblo donde
hay muchas familias numerosas 10 13
niños es normal aquí
así que si hay contagios los 13 niños
propiciarán el contagio y toda la región
se verá afectada
y en general
la gente quiere vacunarse
pero hay un núcleo duro de creyentes que
no quiere ni oír ni hablar de ello
nixon bake mientras tanto sus dosis de
vacuna anti covide permanecen en la
nevera para consternación de otros
residentes locales que no dudan en
recibir el suero
yo me siento muy incómodo con eso si
miras en los pueblos de los alrededores
hay toda esa gente que está en contra de
la vacunación
no entiendo qué tiene que ver la
religión con eso
no soy practicante pero estoy en contra
de que no se vacunen pone en peligro la
vida de los demás es precisamente este
lazo altruista lo que intenta tocar este
joven protestante
aquejado de una enfermedad cardíaca y
renal ya ha recibido una primera
inyección hoy intenta convencer a su
comunidad de la importancia de la
vacunación
intento guiar a la gente a través de
varias consideraciones el aspecto
teológico el aspecto médico y ético pero
también el amor al prójimo porque
vacunarse no es algo que se hace solo
para uno mismo es también una elección
que tiene un impacto para la gente que
nos rodea
un discurso que parece encontrar cierto
eco en algunas parroquias donde los
antivacunas comienzan a revisar su
posición
creo que empiezo a entender que dios nos
ofrece los medios para prevenir las
enfermedades
de hecho a menudo utilizamos
herramientas para combatir ciertos
síntomas de enfermedades y lo hacemos
sin darnos cuenta realmente
así que si se pone todo junto creo que
hay tantos argumentos sino más a favor
de la vacunación que en contra de la
situación actual de nuestra sociedad con
el coronavirus teniendo tal impacto creo
que ir a recibir la vacuna es lo más
responsable es ajax atrás del francés
world bites de autos
dios o la vacuna una elección que sigue
siendo difícil para estas comunidades
tradicionales